little bit of a cliffhanger on last time
where we said about you know the idea of
proofs program proofs where do we go
from here then
yes so
we can use acta the programming language
also to do proofs
which which means i mean we can do a
number of things
we can prove mathematical theorems very
exciting for some okay
but for the programmer we can actually
certify
our programs we can prove that our
program has certain properties right so
i wanted to do a quite a simple problem
so what i'm going to do is a problem
about lists
so i'm going to define an operation on
lists
which is called reverse and turns the
list around yeah
and what i want to prove is something
maybe quite obvious namely if i turn a
list around and then turn around again
i end up with the list i started right
lots of
properties of programs you want to prove
are actually quite simple intuitively
clear you could say
but
to actually prove them and make sure
that they really hold
is actually still important because some
of the properties you think intuitively
are very clear about your program are
alas
completely wrong because you made just
some stupid mistake some stupid error or
whatever and it doesn't work
but here
we really have to prove
some very
stupid
properties some you can see very from a
mathematical point of view very trivial
theorems but they better for us when we
want to run the program point
so here i i have set things up already
have an acta buffer i've already put in
my
favorite list
one two three okay and what i want to do
is i want to do two things i want to
define a function
a reverse of f
which
gives me a list of
a produce a list of a right
and so the idea is that this
function
reverses a list okay we are going to do
this in a moment
but then once i have done this function
i want to write another function
and
this i call ref
and here is a type so reference
as input gets a list of a
and as output it produces a proof
that if i reverse this list twice so i
do left a's and then ref again
i end up with the list i started
and here i use a dependent type
the equality type and that was
featured in our recent video
about martin hoffman's work so that's
the idea so we first write the program
and then we write another program
and the second program actually tells us
something about the first problem so how
do we write ref okay f of some a's and
now again
how do i write ref i have to apply a
magic trick oh is this this is vin
guardium leviosa exactly
basically
recursion exactly
so first of all i
split
my input it's either
the empty list
or
coins list so if you reverse the empty
list you get the empty list and here how
do we reverse a cons list
so if you think about if you reverse a
list one two three the reverse of one
two three should be three two one right
so what we need to do is if we
recursively reverse
the list
2 3 we get the list 3 2
and then we put the first element at the
end
yeah
so how do you reverse the console list
you you take the tail you recursively
reverse the tail
and then you put your your beginning and
the end yeah you put your head to your
tail
sort of yeah
okay
this means
we need to have a way to put something
at the end of a list so the cons puts
things always in the beginning but now
we have to put it at the end and here i
have a name for this operation
which is called snog
why is this operation called snook oh
i'm there
tell me
is it by chance reverse of cons
very good well done
so we have this operation snork which is
cons backwards right
and okay i'm going to write this in a
minute
i mean that's one way of how to do
software development right i write my
function
and then discover
i need some auxiliary function i just
say okay okay
i'll do this later first of all i do my
function and then i go back and and fill
in the details okay
let's do it so here reverse we do what i
state
we reverse a's
and then we snork
a at the end
okay
so ref is sort of finished but not
really
because now we have to fill in snog how
are we going to do snook what is the
magic word
recursion ah very good
so it'll be curled me first of all
split the list
okay
and if the list is just one element the
output is just the list
with with one element if i yeah if i
snog an element
at the end of the empty list i get a
list just containing a
and here okay that's the x i'm not going
to replace the x by a because my other
parameter is called x let's keep it as x
um so what am i going to do
if i put a at the end my list will begin
with x again right
but i have to
snog
my a at the end
of ace
okay
so let's see let's see if i if i if i
if i do this snork let's first test snog
i say snog
my favorite list
and then i put four at the end i'm not
very creative okay and we get that just
works and now let's take let's test our
f
so ref of l1 is 321
works and
you can also try
exactly what happens
test
if you reverse
l1 and then reverse it again
we end up with a
list
from the beginning
but okay now let's prove that that's
always the case so we prove this
by writing another program
and this program is interesting it has a
dependent type right we see here the
arrow
the input is a list a
but we give it a name namely ace
and the output
is
a proof
and this proof depends
on the input this is from the input
occurs here
okay before we start we need to
understand
what we can do with equality so let me
just copy some lines some comments here
so here's the definition of equality
uh
from the library
so i say
two things are equal
the only way to to prove this
is called raffle the raffle is a
canonical proof of equality
like zero and success or canonical
natural numbers
and using this idea i can prove some
useful properties of equality so here's
one i call tons for transitivity which
is a function
giving given a proof that a is equal to
b and another proves that b equals to c
it produces a proof that a equals to c
now it's not difficult to write this
program it's a one-liner because we only
have to
match the first input against raffle and
i explain this a little bit in the video
about martin hoffman
here's another useful library function
we need if we have a function from a to
b
and we know that the inputs are equal
the outputs are also equal
and it turns out again we can prove this
by just pattern matching okay
so this is already done in the library
so now
how do we prove reference how do we
write this program magic word
recursion very good
okay so the pattern match on ace
and so that is the first case
is that a ref of wrath of nil is equal
to nil
now it turns out this is very easy
because what is ref of wrath of nil
ref of nil is nil
and wrath of nil is nil
so
it must be there's nothing to be proved
here
they're just identical if you're looking
actually in acta
arcta tells us that the goal is to prove
that nil is equal to nil because it has
already calculated that the ref of wrath
of nil
is nil so all what you have to prove
is
nil is equal to nil
and that's rifle
okay very easy this case is not so easy
so let me let me explain this a little
bit what we want to prove it's down here
let me just copy this we want to prove
that f of f of
x counts a's is the same as x cos a's
now
akta calculates this
and it it evaluates the program as much
as it can so it it says ref of x con
something is the same as snork of graph
i mean that is our definition of ref
but now
it's a bit stuck
because
it it doesn't know
what is ref of snog but what is ref of
snook if i reverse a list where i put an
element
at the end
this element will
move to the front
right
and the rest is reversed so what is ref
of snog
of x so this x moves to the front
and the left moves inside so it's f
of
f
of a's
and now why is this one equal
to
x-cons a's
now yeah
because ref of a s is equal to a's
this is just the recursive call
to reference
always prove this
and we can recursively call ref
to prove this thing
okay
so here we have to combine two
equalities
this one
no actually this one and this one
and combining equalities
we use this trans program because if you
have two equalities we put them together
saying trans okay the first step
is to move a snog
over a ref into a cons all right
so really what we want we want and we
want a quality here
namely that rf
of
snog
axis a
is equal
to
a
cons graph
of x's all right that's exactly the
property we need
and this is just another program it's i
call it snog
okay
and now we have to we have to quantify
all these things
so we have a function
which gets
as input a list and an element
and then
prove this
and here is the same situation that we
have before when we wrote the program
this is an auxiliary program
and these auxiliary programs they are
called lemmas in a
meta mistake
they are called lemmas in in mathematics
so these are just auxiliary programs
okay so what do we do
we first call our ref snork refsnoc the
first element is ace so if you look at
this proof the first list here
is the left of a so we have to tell it
ref of ace and
what's in the end is the x
okay let me just
make a bit of space
and now
the second thing is is sort of easy we
just have to apply
this ref ref as is equal to a's
but we have to use this under the cons
so here's a cons in front
and that's exactly where we need this
other operation
maybe it's called com
so we use the fact
that cons
preserves equality so
so we use this function which uses a
lambda which says basically that if you
cons the same element in front of a list
and two equal lists will produce two
equal outputs and now let me put another
shed in here oh it's not an a
that's an x and there should be an x's
okay
so
i open the shed and i have this other
shed left and this is actually
exactly
what i want to prove
but for a shorter list and here really
we have to
do recursive call
okay
so
this is
the proof
that the ref
that reversing twice is equal to its
input
but it uses this refs knock and
okay i'm not going to
complete this program or this proof
actually uh it's two-liner it's not it's
not difficult and it only uses what i've
already introduced but i leave this as
an exercise but what we see here is
that we can write programs
which prove properties about other
programs
and
maybe you have noticed that there is
that there are two magic words which
turn out to be the same the one magic
word is from programming recursion
and there is another scary magic work
for mathematics
which is called
induction
and it turns out
these two are the same because here we
could really do a proof by induction
but it is nothing else
but recursion what we can do
with this technology
is
a number of things so one thing is in
academia when you write a mathematical
papers or theoretical papers
where there are theorems involved we can
check that these theorems are really
true by proving them formally and that's
really quite a widespread nowadays
already
but they're also industrial applications
and they're already
starting to be used where uh some
programs which are quite uh security
sensitive or
financially important
uh
are formally verified and they can be
guaranteed that they have certain
properties that's a lot of extra work
and
we are working on the technology
to make it easier to do these proofs you
know we want to make them more automatic
need lots of help maybe use some machine
learning to learn how to do them but in
the end we want to have a program
by whatever means it's produced which
gives us a certificate that another
program
does its job
canonical numbers for the numerals and
here when we define construction
on equality proofs it's enough to do
this for the canonical one which is
reflexivity
which means i only have to you could
view rgb as in some sense 3d so the
first plane is r r g and b or vice versa